welcome to the climate show where I will
be revealing how in the midst of a
climate crisis many businesses are being
forced to turn to these diesel
generators to make their electricity
they're one of the dirtiest forms of
power generation
[Music]
hello this week we're going power mad
coming up we've been uncovering our
growing dirty diesel secret plus the
billionaire funding the climate-friendly
Regeneration of Ukraine
how best to cook in Africa firewood or
bottled gas and after expending all that
energy I think we'll need a little
retail therapy can Black Friday really
become green
when your energy bill hits the doormat
or in the inbox have you ever wondered
if you could find a different power
source well thanks Jim an investigation
for this program has discovered that
many companies and even some households
are switching from Maine's power to
generating electricity from diesel
because they say it's cheaper and fear
of power Cuts is fueling the appetite
for generators the problem diesel
generation is bad for the climate and
worse for local air pollution
Chop Chop it's less than a month to go
before Christmas
and new its butchers in the Oxfordshire
town of tame is cracking awning
Readiness for their busiest period
Tom newett's family have been in the
food business here for over 200 years he
employs 20 staff and alongside the fresh
meat makes approaching 10 000 pies and
packets a week but the environmental
story we're doing here is not actually
about the meat itself it's about what
goes on Backstage all the freezing
chilling and cooking using so much
energy and where all that electricity
comes from
we have a lot of a lot of freezer units
um all of which we're building stocks
for for our festive period pork pie
sausage rolls are all big uses of power
and this year he's using a different
power source
we're using a diesel generator
generating a power to run the whole site
how come
purely down to financial and the cost of
pure cost really that the energy costs
are so high in order for us to be
competitive and stay in business we've
needed to save that huge chunk of our
overhead give me a feeling of how much
money or how much power we're talking
about here
[Music]
350 000 pounds is our
forecasted energy consumption over the
air
and hopefully on a fair wind we should
be about a third of the cost by running
a diesel running our diesel generators
he had the generator anyway as emergency
backup but now it's running 24 7. and
getting through this two and a half
thousand liter tank every week I mean in
terms of environment and climate change
these things aren't great does that
trouble you at all it does and we are
doing things within the business
having an electric van which I've got it
on order and we've changed all of our
packaging over to uh reusable and I've
improved trays which are recyclable and
all of our packaging now is paper rather
than using Plastics
power generators are similar to diesel
engines in cars
gases and particles that cause pollution
linked to conditions like asthma lung
disease cancer and even babies of lower
birth weight what's really bad about
diesels is big particulates big chunks
of carbon and they're going up into the
air that we all live in and breathe
and when it comes to climate change
diesel generators pump out 17 more
carbon dioxide than the grid for every
unit of electricity when we generate
with Renewables like wind they just
don't generate any of these factors any
of these chemicals at all so you know
diesel is just the wrong thing to be
doing at this point in time when we know
so much and how to do things in a much
better way but the fear of blackouts and
the high cost of grid electricity
overrides any environmental doubts for
dealers generators are flying off the
shelves almost nothing is in stock it's
just to see a red out of stock out of
stock out of stock all of the similar
generator suppliers we spoke to reported
soaring demand unheard of it's everyone
that we speak to they just say it's
crazy we we can't keep up since we've
had these large energy hikes we've seen
both you know residential customers and
but predominantly business customers now
uh exploring options to run their their
businesses from their own power
generation equipment mainly industrial
diesel generators
more and more of our Mains electricity
comes from clean frequently cheap
sources like wind and solar but the
bills we actually pay have been
escalated by the gas shortage the result
business is driven to shop around for a
bargain even a polluting one
most of the businesses that are
switching to generators are driven to it
by the need to keep energy bills down
and Diesel generation seems so much
cheaper and when you look at Power
prices for businesses you can see why
the top line here is the price of
electricity the bottom one Diesel and
you can see how in the most recent
period the cost of electricity surges
upwards increasing the Gap to diesel
the government does have plans to reform
the electricity market so cheaply
generated renewable electricity might
become lower cost for consumers but in
the meantime is there any way of cutting
your bill without burning fossil fuels
well one answer could be batteries if
you have solar panels then batteries
enable you to store power so you can use
it when you need it and anyone with
cheaper nighttime electricity can bank
that overnight for future use powervolt
is the only British manufacturer of big
domestic batteries
foreign
[Music]
I run the business development for
powervolt
and this is where we manufacture our
smart domestic energy storage devices or
batteries
so so this is a large eight kilowatt
hour PV compact
a solar panel on a property will export
to the grid about 50 to the generation
that it that it produces every year
what the battery does is capture as much
as it can of that excess generation so
that then when you come home in the
evening and let's say at six o'clock
it's after work you're making your tea
instead of you then pulling electricity
back from the grid again having lost a
lot of it the battery will then
discharge so that you are not consume
electricity from the grid the other way
is to be able to store any off-peak
energy that you can capture from the
grid if you're on a time of use tariff
we know that we need to reach climate
change objectives and get into Net Zero
by 2050 what the batteries themselves
will do is maximize your
self-consumption of Renewable Power on
site so that green electron that you
generate is the one that you consume
which is really really important for
cutting your carbon footprint there's
also the opportunity for you to reduce
your Reliance on the grid which will
also support it because it's under so
much strain at the moment
why aren't these units in uh in every
home in the UK firstly the technology is
quite new so the Market's only really
just just appearing but also the units
are very expensive it's not everybody
that can that can put them in
um but you know hopefully as the
technology evolves and becomes cheaper
and also Energy prices continue to rise
so it means the um the investment
rationale is is much stronger for
installing them that we can see a large
proliferation in their in their use in
the UK
focused
now we love to get your climate and
environment questions into the show and
try to answer them this one came in on
Twitter from Julius moisigi and it's on
our theme of power prices in Uganda we
have sunshine and rivers that can
generate electricity but our power is
very expensive people continue to cut
down trees for fuel how can
International bodies help
for an answer we turn to Dr winislas
katagira at Macarena University in
Kampala
thank you Julius for the question indeed
electricity and solar provide the
cleanest energy for cooking however the
high cost of electricity in Uganda
remains prohibited for domestic users to
use it for cooking the other clean
option we have is LPG on commonly known
as gas however its use in Uganda is very
low and only stands at 0.8 percent
International donors could support any
investing in the LPG sector as a clean
transition for sub-Saharan Africa the
challenge is that LPG Still Remains
viewed as a fossil fuel despite evidence
that is the best screen option at scale
now
increased LPG uptake will bring health
benefits cause minimum or no impact to
The Climate while protecting forests
now Russia has turned its Firepower
against Ukraine's energy Network this
week missile and drone strikes have
knocked out power supplies across the
country just as temperatures settle well
below zero now one of the world's
richest men Australian mining
billionaire Andrew Forrest has offered
to give Ukraine hundreds of millions of
dollars to rebuild their energy
infrastructure seed money for what he
hopes will be a multi-billion dollar pot
but he doesn't want to finance fossil
fuel power station he wants Renewable
Power Bill back greener
I do thanks very much indeed for joining
us without wishing to be a bit a bit
crude about it what size of check have
you put into this in order to get the
ball rolling I'll get the ball
rolling in US Dollars just to get it
going Tom and um and I really think uh
that indicates to Global Investors
around the world that this particular
Global investor has got a pretty good
track record you know he's willing to
back this in hard
um and we're really encouraging
investors to answer the call I've had
calls from all over the world
um and you people who really see the
good sense in rebuilding what Russia's
flat out destroying in Ukraine and
destroying more and more every day
especially when we see their attacks on
the infrastructure the power networks
Etc 500 million is is an awful lot of
money but sadly it could end up being a
drop in the ocean or a bit of a drop in
the Wasteland there how much indication
have you had of more money coming in
look I
My overall Target was 100 billion
dollars with a multiplier impact of
eight to ten times that's 800 billion to
a trillion in economic impact but
Ukraine should not build back that old
Soviet era rubbish you know you know the
old telephone lines for communication
let's go fully digital the old coal
mines and the old coal-fired Power
stations even even the even the uranium
fired power stations they can all be
replaced with green with battery let's
move Ukraine to full green digital
economy the first in Europe the great
thing is about business I like
philanthropy or even government grants
when business comes in time it brings
the best know-how it brings the best
technology it survives on its own record
it must be very good so when that comes
in you marry that with that huge
Ukrainian
intelligence that the fact that they've
got more Masters and phds of engineering
per square kilometer I think any economy
on Earth put that together with that
intellect and then marry that again Tom
with the enthusiasm the energy the
commitment the Loyalty The Vigor which
that population has to rebuild itself
after the Dreadful
Injustice the cruelty which has been
meted out upon them they're going to
come out of the blocks at full gallop
tell me a little about your own Journey
because you you've made a lot of money
out of out of metals and things that
frankly are rather rather polluting and
dirty do you now have the kind of zeal
of a reformed sinner on this yeah no
thank you for that Tom actually Tom so
many people say that I just want to
remind everyone there's no carbon
whatsoever in Iron ore so I ship a
carbon-free the smelting of it is is
pretty uh it emits a lot of carbon
dioxide that is a big problem I feel a
deep responsibility even though I don't
do it Tom I feel a very deep
responsibility to replace what my
customers are putting in with my iron
ore which is metallurgical coal and
replace it with green hydrogen now the
instant they do that they can power this
planet with all the steel it will ever
need highest quality whatever at the
lowest cost because that green hydrogen
price will come down and will certainly
be cheaper than cold because coal again
a fossil fuel the more you use it the
more expensive it becomes green hydrogen
the more we use it the less expensive it
becomes but it is green hydrogen is
ferociously expensive at the moment
sadly at very energy intensive to
produce
um do you really see a near future where
Mining and and smelting operations and
other things can really be fueled by
this in effect zero carbon energy come
the real dollar value of a barrel of oil
a couple hundred years ago when it was
spreading all over the world was about
six thousand dollars so I just want to
remind everyone that everyone was using
this fantastic new energy they could
transport wherever they wanted to right
because up to that point they'll kind of
log fired Wood-Fired Hydro powered that
was it but now they had an energy they
could transport anywhere people were
pining up six thousand dollars a barrel
so you know when people say oh my God
it's going to be more expensive than
fossil fuel I said well heaven forbid
have you ever seen the price of a
computer Moore's Law it's doubled in
efficiency harved in cost every couple
of years same is going to happen here I
mean for it's really the fossil fuel
sector Tom he whinges about this I've
got to say you know you're going to be
overwhelmed by the youth you're going to
be overwhelmed by popular demand to get
out of the road when there's a full
Green Solution which the more you use it
the cheaper more abundant becomes
everyone's cost of living goes down
everyone's standard of living goes up
can't be weaponized because it's
everywhere Tom
then that's what you that's what the
world will do and they're going to look
back on the fossil fuel error Thomas
kind of a yeah okay we're pretty stupid
for a couple hundred years and but
finally we caught on Andrew Flores thank
you very much indeed thank you so much
Tom
of course Peace is the priority in
Ukraine but when that comes it would be
great to see it built back in a nature
and climate-friendly way well this
weekend shops are a wash with Black
Friday promotions ramping up to
Christmas a chance to snap up a bargain
or a dangerous driver of climate
punishing consumerism
Christmas the time of year when we're
encouraged to buy buy
lured in by offers of savings
but with the UN estimating people are
purchasing 60 more clothes and wearing
them for half as long is it time to
reassess our shopping habits I'm being
told that everything is cheaper and so
therefore I should get out there and go
and see what is available we now have
actually a ton of really exciting
Alternatives it's about reframing in our
minds much of this narrative and looking
at the repair work that can be done the
ReUse of of old things charity Shops and
and second-hand clothing shops and
that's where shops like the good store
come in
run by environmental charity groundwork
they're creating jobs in the community
and giving old products a new lease of
life
even their plants are reused from this
Summer's Wimbledon we have a whole range
of different items which show different
routes into sustainability we have reuse
and refurbishments we also have new
products and they're more sustainable
for lots of different reasons so we have
beauty products that are made out of
coffee grounds that have been collected
by bike from coffee shops around South
London we have bags which have been made
out of broken bouncy castles and deck
chairs we have items which are for
instance made out of trees which have
been filled in London who either because
they've fallen in a storm or because
they've been cut down by their Council
and rather than going off to be cheap
they've been made into furniture by
social Enterprise in East London
buying or sharing pre-loved and Greener
items has become an attractive Trend in
recent years but in terms of scale it's
far from mainstream making consumerism
Planet positive will need many more of
us to change our shopping habits
time for another question John
Scott in touch via the Sky News app
asking with Germany launching the first
hydrogen-driven train why aren't we
forging ahead with this very clean form
of energy well John mix news for you
here we are going to spend a big chunk
of the show on hydrogen but not till
next week please be patient and watch it
then
for more on the Relentless March of
diesel during the climate crisis and how
we might halt it download the Sky News
climate cast from wherever you get your
podcasts if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest episode
but that's it for the climate show don't
forget we'll bring you the latest every
weekday at half past three here on Sky
News but for now goodbye
[Music]